you know I did stuff that should have
been a home run and then it wasn't like
eternals you know it's it's it was it
was uh Oscar winning director the one of
the craziest casts you know you had like
Legends you had Salma Hayek you had
Angelina Jolie you had new people who
are amazing Brian Tyreek Henry Barry
kogen who have both been nominated for
Oscar you thought it was just a slam
dunk I was like this is going to be a
slam dunk and it'll be great it'll open
all the stuff for me when that movie
came out and the reviews weren't good
that was very very tough for me and I
realized that too much of how I'm
evaluating what I want to do is based on
the result what other people think of it
me too my whole life was that